all right here we go gentlemen lady why
are you dissecting your class she was
mean to us at school with a million
sexually hard sexy fun buckets
[Music]
what's a usually sexually hard sexual
fun bucket sometimes it feels like I'm
the only floor peon who wants to escape
this garbage planet hey hey you're the
one who chose to land here I hate
everything here I'm a baby biscuit
we have been stranded here for a year
how is that not a problem for you I like
baby biscuits out of the baby biscuit
thing in there that's how we make this
show oh my god Oh God Oh what the [ __ ]
is going on oh my one regret I didn't
read enough manuals tell everyone you
know to take time to read more manuals I
have to focus on getting in with the
cool kids my plan is to just slip in the
seat do nothing done eventually it'll
seem normal that I'm there hmm
work for Hulu I have the whole day
planned out we're gonna buy lottery
tickets and we're gonna win a million
dollars but then we give it all that's a
tip to a waitress and totally change
your life you go girlfriend you buy
yourself a new pair of shoes my plan is
to sit in dim light spray nutrients on
my stumps so that you know until they
grow out and then I'm gonna study repair
manual Corbett Ron baby baby baby sweet
baby biscuit boy school sucks okay we
don't like it doesn't matter if you like
it we're on a mission I didn't like baby
biscuits and now I do and they're
delicious what you can't shrink people
you good killer we heard just
reprogramming her a little bit like
maybe we could reprogram her to like
baby biscuits are we in trouble mr. baby
Biscay
we will discuss your grounding later so
we're up prepares some baby biscuits for
tonight and let her go
okay maybe we need to come up with a new
the baby biscuit thing is getting to be
[Music]